تكثف روسيا التجنيد لحربها
على أوكرانيا من خلال مقطع فيديو جديد على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
يبدو أنه يسخر من الرجال لدفعهم إلى ترك
وظائفهم اليومية مثل حراس الأمن
وسائقي سيارات الأجرة ليصبحوا اقتباسات من
الرجال الحقيقيين في القتال، كلير سيباستيان من سي إن إن على
الهواء مباشرة  في لندن، اه حسنًا كلير، اه من الرائع
رؤيتك ليس لدي الكثير من ردود الفعل
هناك باستثناء اه، يبدو أنك تعرف
كل ما يعتقدون أنه سيعمل ولكن ما هو
الرد الذي تم عبر الإنترنت وفي الحياة الواقعية،
حسنًا إيما، هذه حملة جديدة جدًا
هذا الفيديو  تم إصداره قبل يومين فقط، لذلك من
الصعب تقييم تأثيره في الوقت الحالي
كأداة تجنيد، لكن من
الواضح جدًا أن هذا مصمم لتجنيد
الرجال مباشرة في الحرب في
أوكرانيا، وتستخدم وزارة الدفاع
الشعار الذي يُترجم باللغة الروسية
تقريبًا كـ  انضم إلى جيشك الخاص واستخدم
الاختصار الروسي للعمليات العسكرية الخاصة،
لذا ليس هناك شك في ذلك،
أعتقد أنه لكي نكون منصفين، تستخدم الكثير من الجيوش
مقاطع فيديو للتجنيد تلعب على
أفكار الثقة في قوة
الرجولة في بعض النواحي ولكن هذا
يتحدث أيضًا  بالنسبة للتحديات التي تواجهها روسيا
في تجنيد أفراد مدربين
في ساحة المعركة، رأينا مع
حملة التجنيد هذه في الخريف
حيث قاموا بتجنيد 300000 فرد غير مدرب،
أعتقد أن هذا
نوع مختلف تمامًا من التجنيد الذي
نشهده الآن